Speaker 1: So we're continuing to cover, as
we've done on the bonus show, the detention
and imprisonment and trial of WNBA player Brittney
Griner in Russia. And unfortunately, the situation
itself is sort of opaque. And the Russian
justice system is not exactly what we would call
fair and open. The prosecution rate is, you
know, outrageously high. And there's all sorts of
history there of everything from planted evidence
to everything you can imagine. And also, it does
appear from the reports we have now that Brittney
Griner supposedly accidentally had a very,
very small amount of drugs with her in Russia. And
the United States is now trying to get her out of
what they consider to be an unjust detention.
And there is a prisoner swap that is now being
considered. Well, Donald Trump is siding with
Russia on this one again. Trump sides with Russia
calls jailed American Brittney Griner spoiled.
Donald Trump appeared on the what show is this?
We've seen clips the Clay Travis and Buck Sexton
show and says Brittney Griner is spoiled and he
wouldn't have made this deal to get her out.
Speaker 3: Would you have made, by the way,
the offer for Brittney Griner and Viktor Bout that
Russia has put forward where they'll trade this
arms dealers 25 years for arms dealing all
over the world for the WNBA player and also
believe a former Marine is being held there.
She went in there, loaded up with drugs
into a hostile territory.
Speaker 1: Okay. Loaded up
with drugs. We're going to talk about in a moment.
Speaker 3: They're very vigilant about drugs. They
don't like drugs. And she got caught.
Speaker 1: And by the way, Trump
loves when authoritarian strongmen just
go crazy about anything drug related.
He thought it was amazing that do territory used
to kill drug dealers. And Trump recently said, for
every drug dealer you kill, you save 500 people.
How he came up with that number, I don't know.
Speaker 3: We're supposed to get her.
And she makes a lot of money, I guess.
But we're supposed to get her out for a Absolut
killer. And one of the biggest arms dealers in
the world killed many Americans, killed many
people. And he's going to get a free card
and we're going to get her. She knew you don't go
in there loaded up with drugs and she admitted it.
I assume she admitted it without too much
force because it is what it is. And it's.
Speaker 1: Sometimes there's force, but.
Speaker 3: It doesn't seem like a very good trade,
does it? He's an absolute one of the worst in
the world. And he's going to be given his freedom
because a potentially spoiled person
goes into Russia loaded up with drugs.
Speaker 1: Okay, now what? By spoiled? Does
he just mean that she's black? Like, is this
as simple as she's gay and black? Which to Trump
means that she's spoiled. First of all, Trump has
pardoned tons of criminals. That's number one. So
clearly, there's not in principle a problem he has
with saying, here's someone who's been sentenced
for something, but I'm going to pardon them. Trump
talks about loaded up with drugs. I'm right there
in saying, when you go places like Russia, you've
got to be really careful about what you have with
you. I'm right there. In fact, I don't think I
would even go. She had 0.7 grams of cannabis oil.
Now that's legal in her home state of Arizona.
It's illegal in many states. In the United
States, it's not legal in Russia. I completely
am with you there. But 0.7 grams is not exactly
exactly being loaded up with drugs. And yet the
Russian media has referred to it as a significant
amount of drugs. That's obviously not true. She
also had a doctor's note for the cannabis oil. I
understand that doesn't make it legal in Russia,
but she explained that she pleaded guilty. She
said it was inadvertent. You know, it's like we've
got Madison Cawthorn, quote, accidentally bringing
guns, trying to bring guns past TSA onto planes
multiple times. And the right is perfectly
satisfied, saying those are honest mistakes.
Here is 0.7 grams of cannabis oil with a
doctor's note. And now all of a sudden,
we're supposed to believe her detention is
fair and not at all politically motivated. So
you knew that Trump was going to come up
with something like this. But the pattern is,
once again, he's defending Russia and Russia's
authoritarian police state. They're completely
absurd justice system. I was let me see if I can
even find it. Russian court's conviction rate.
In 2018. The gross conviction rate. I believe
gross means it doesn't account for repeals and
reversals. The gross conviction rate was 99%.
Yeah. There you go. In 2018. 0.25% of Russian
court cases ended in an acquittal. That's an
incredibly efficient judicial system, isn't it? So
doesn't I get it? You got to be careful. Whenever
I go anywhere, I make sure to bring nothing. I
don't bring anything there. And I don't bring
anything back. That's my thing. But 0.7 grams of
cannabis oil. And now Trump goes, Oh, well, she's
spoiled. Give me a break. Absolutely outrageous.